in the show nearing a milestone episode
so to speak 200 yeah what's that like to
be able to kick back and say you know
it's it's historical in terms of
television with how many shows make it
to air what's it like to be in that
position well certainly shows have made
it to 200 episodes before but usually in
their first run we took an 11-year break
at like episode 194 and we none of us
thought we'd get this milestone why
would we so this is particularly special
that that we get a second a second
chance in love is there a new sense of I
mean I'm sure you're very appreciative
of the first round but is there a
different sense of appreciation when you
come back and get as you said a second
chance so to speak absolutely I mean
it's this there's stages of it you know
with an eight year run you can't believe
your luck and then you're in love with
each other and then it becomes your day
job and you get picked up for two
seasons you take it for granted and then
by the end of your like we should end
this so that we do and then you get 11
years off for you and you get a chance
at this and every moment you savor every
moment we really are I mean it sounds
Pollyanna but we are all just running
around making out all the time loving
our crew and so it's Shaun drops his
pants of a Thursday and and it's just
it's a real they say you can't go home
again but we got to have you changed I'm
a little older still attractive though
no wiser no wiser I'm a little Dumber
you can't remember much but no but
you're right you're right still
attractive with that it's it's it's not
the harsh lighting so clearly clearly
something's working I'm starting my own
line of Mena's products which is really
just really did cause it's just a series
of layers and cause we put over the car
over thank you thank you you know so
this show I was just talking about how
this show was one of the first in terms
of in to really delve into sexual
orientation
become like a flagpole so to speak for
it and now it's become more commonplace
in television or maybe the audience is
the most more acceptable of that or
something rather are you are you proud
of that that there was a certain sense
of social responsibility that came with
this show absolutely absolutely and and
it was you know as we've always said it
was never intentional it was a big
splashy sitcom and as time went by we
started to realize the power we had to
reach people that wouldn't otherwise be
at a at a pride parade or or listening
to a speech from someone that they're
gonna they're gonna get it through a
different medium and they were getting
it through Jack and will they were
seeing gay men to very different kinds
of gay men plus Joe with Larry and all
these other there's a lot of gay
characters on this show and so hence you
get to see depth and variety and not
some stereotype you were raised with so
we were always really proud that the
show blossomed that way and then we went
off the air and who remembers well it
turns out one day that Joe Biden
remembered and talked about this is an
educational tool you know to you know
way if Jack heard educational tool tool
but it it has become something bigger
than we ever thought what comes with
that now knowing that is there a
different sense of conversations that
happen now because you feel a sense of
responsibility in the show you're like
hey we should probably tackle this let's
do this let's make sure absolutely we
you know we always want to use our power
for good but first of all we want to use
our power to make the laugh that's a key
thing if the show's not funny if it's
pedantic or a luxury then it's of no use
but if we can manage to find a subject
that another the show's not going to
tackle why would that is a perfect
subject for Will and Grace to tackle but
in a hilarious way then we're gonna be
going down roads that wouldn't even have
dreamed of perhaps 15 years ago what can
we expect we know you
drought yes go work with grace mm-hmm
what can we expect for your character
driven through that transitional period
well two words hilarity there-there the
obviously a great team and but they're
gonna drive each other insane as they as
they work together and and will loves
having no overhead so he's just working
out of her office and and that's gonna
be fun and we're doing one where
actually we just read it at the table
today where we realized how much more
it's not just building grace off and
just came home at the end of the day I
had to share well this happened to me
will this happen to me and now they get
to spend their day together and it's
it's gonna add a whole lot more to the
show